την ιδιότητα είναι ένας οργανισμός στες τηλεπικοινωνίας ο οποίος πρέπει να υγάζεις κέρδος αλλάαπό την
ώρα που ιδιοκτήτις μας είναι το κράτος δηλαδι ο κόσμος είναι ο ιδιοκτήτης μας έχουμε
ακόμε ένα καφέλλο που φορούμε το οποίο λέει ότι πρέπει να σκεφτόμα στην πάντα και
την κοινωνία καταρχή κάθε χρόνο έναν μεγάλον πως οστών από τα κέρδι της σίδα επιστρέφονται
πίσω στο κράτος με τη μορφή μερίσματος οπότε αυτό το πράγμα τη σημαινή σημαίνει ότι
δίνουμε δεν δεν παίρνουμε καθόλου επιδότηση από το κράτος αλλά δίννουμε εμείς πίσω στο κράτος
έναν πολύ σημαντικό πωςο επίσης κάθε πράγμα που κάμνουμε το ζηγίζουμε για οφέλει που έχει
προς την κοινωνία και όχι μόνο τα ωφέλει που έχει στη σίδα αν κοιτάζζαμε μόνον
τα ωφέλει τη σίδα δεν θα βάζζαμε αυυζή σε όλι την κύπρο στα χωριά δεν
συμφέρει επιχειρηματικά να πάεις να βάλεις να επενδήσεις να βαλισφαιυζή και αυτό α αποδεικνίεται γιατί
οι ανταγωνιστέες μας πουν ιδιοτικές εταιρείες δεν επίαν να βάλο εμείς επίαμε ναβάλουμε διότι σκέψει
μας είναι με τον βάλουμε εφαιυζή σε όλι την κύπρον βοηθούμε και τις τοπικές κοινότητες
των κόσμον ο οποίος δεν είναι στην στυν ήδια ανευνοική θέση όπως είναι η κάτοική
των πολεων και βοηθούμε και το τη χώρα να αναπτύξει την οικονομίατης σε σε περιοχές
γιογραφικές που αυτή τη στιγμή είναι υποβαθνισμένες αυτό δεν είναι προς το συμφέρον τη σίδα
προς το συμφέρο της χώρας και της κοινωνίας υτόν ένα μικρόν παράδειγμα αλλά θέλω α
σας πω σε όλα τα πράγματα που κάμνουμε που περνούμε μέσα από αυτόν τω το
φίλτρο βοηθά την κοινωνία ν αυτό που θα κάνουμε ιδεν τη βοήθα και όπου μπορούμε
να κάνουμε ενέργιες που βοηθούν τη χώρα και την κοινωνία το κάνου σχέση με τους
νέους ήταν το λόι αλτή τους στα μπράματη